How many more?
How many more colleges?
How many more classrooms?
How many more movie theaters?
How many more houses of faith?
How many more shopping malls?
How many more street corners?
How many more?
Enough.
Demand a plan...
...right now...
...as a mom,...
...as a dad,...
...as a friend,...
...as a husband,...
...as a wife,...
...as a human being.
For the children of Sandy Hook,...
...demand a plan.
No more list of names.
It's not too soon.
It's too late.
Now is the time...
...before we all know someone who loved someone on that list.
No more lists.
No more...
...who they might have been, no more...
...if we had just done something yesterday.
It's time.
We can do better than this.
It's time for our leaders to act.
Demand a plan...
...right now.
You, demand it!
Enough.